It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
Friday!
It's Friday.
It's your week!
And today we're your hosts on FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Can you believe it?
Today is our 146th episode!
Thank you for joining us on the showcase of BAU BAU!
Good morning!
Good morning first time viewers!
Oh, maybe not.
You sleep in.
But today you're awake.
Yeah, I did hear crows on the ground.
Yeah, I saw that.
You thought this was the fourth episode.
Well, you would be mistaken, huh?
Not quite.
A hundred times.
No.
Yeah.
A hundred times maybe.
A bit more.
I said not quite.
But for Ruffians that are joining us for the first time and other Ruffians that are like, what is this?
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
I said it twice, okay?
Don't get confused, okay?
I'm confused now.
Well, our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please say a thought to the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
That's all BAU BAU to our brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You ready?
Ready for Friday?
Yeah.
You know, I have a good feeling about today.
How do you feel, Rolfie?
Do you feel good?
Misunderstanding.
What do you want?
No misunderstanding.
It's Friday!
Friday?
Yeah.
You ready?
Ready!
Sleepy.
It was rough, rough.
Not so good of a sleep.
Ruffians.
It's morning okay!
I know you're sleepy!
But you have to wake up.
Okay, okay.
And we're here to bring some pup into your day.
Let's get going.
Now for some more bad news.
More bad news, Moco-chan?
That implies that you know FUWAMOCO's bad news.
I was implying that waking up is bad news.
Thanks goodness.
You know?
That was dark.
Wow!
Pero Sighting!
Where was Pero Sighting?
Let's take a look.
Someone looks comfy there, huh?
Melty.
And sort of a cute one, but nasty, huh?
Yeah.
And what's with the fangs, huh?
Help, help.
Hi!
It should've been me!
Let me be there!
Ruffians!
You wouldn't be like that if you sat on Mari-senchou-senpai's lap.
Right?
Why are you sitting on Senchou-senpai's lap?
Hi!
What?
Should've been you!
Hi!
Last time I said this was FUWAMOCO Morning and not
Morning senchou morning.
Let's all say ahoy!
Not bad, no?
Senchou-senpai morning.
No.
Hmm.
Ha?
Moco-chan, you gonna be?
Oh, Ruffians.
Ruffians!
Are you Ruffians or are you ichimi, ha?
Ha!
Maybe everyone's confused, ha?
Look what you've done.
Because you know, Senchou-senpai is pretty, pretty wonderful.
I could talk about her lots and lots, but this is FUWAMOCO morning, right?
Yeah.
And you know, I think this is inappropriate, Ruffians, you know.
You know, if Pero's tired from flopping his little wings around and doing damn dog things, you know, Senchou-senpai's lap is not the place to take a rest.
Okay?
It's not a place for a rest.
No.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO.
Better place would be the garbage can.
Yeah.
No, uh... Trash compactor!
Trash compactor!
That's a step up from a garbage can!
Those kind of things, yeah.
Don't take a rest in the trash compactor, okay, Ruffians?
Even if... Can't stop talking, I will send you someplace fine.
Even then, I wouldn't want you to take a rest in the trash compactor, okay?
Yeah.
Well, I guess we're just going to have to do some... Even Gaido got it.
Even in this case, I wouldn't want you going there!
BAU BAU.
It's Friday, Ruffians!
It's a good day!
No trash compactors today, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's the Ruffians!
I know we share this with you lots and lots and you know, you probably know that
How we feelin' and everything.
But we wanna say it again!
Ruffians, thank you!
Thank you!
Cuz you know, there's a reason.
A reason.
There's supposed to come a reason.
We don't need a reason to say thank you normally, but this time there is another one.
We do!
Yeah!
I covered a Let Me Be With You by Rod Taylor B. Newton from the anime Tobit has hit over 1 million views on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Did you get all that?
Those played a multiple, Moco-chan.
I played a bit of a multiple, hi.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Yeah, we're so surprised and super happy that you like it so much!
You know, since it's a song that we've loved for many years and it means a lot to us.
But I... You know, we didn't really think that maybe...
It will be very well known that I am a-
It's a little bit old.
Thank you for listening to it lots and lots!
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
I love FUWAMOCO so much, too!
FUWAMOCO is good, too!
Definitely, it's a song that's unforgettable.
If you haven't heard it yet, you know?
Please check it out!
It's really, really cute!
It will get stuck in your head for sure, too.
You know, you'll be like... All the time.
But yeah, like Moco-chan said, you know, it's a...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Okay.
Can I hold you tonight?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You know Biboo, right?
You know the sparkling gem of Advent.
Yes, hololive English -Advent-.
Yeah, you know also criminally clumsy.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yay!
She went on a trip.
Biboo went on a trip!
Yeah.
And I... See I...
She fell off an escalator three steps.
I had quite the tumble.
Quite the tumble, yeah.
I could see no Ruffians!
We're gonna be seeing Biboo!
You know when Biboo was like... We know we heard that she fell.
We have to go get her some band-aids!
I don't wanna get band-aids!
Why is Biboo not carrying band-aids around with her all the time?
I think she would know by now.
Yeah, but.
Now she is.
Now she will be.
But you know, we got her band-aids.
Yeah.
But then we, you know, we're like, okay, let's take a look.
She was a lot more scratched up than we expected.
Yeah, she had some, some, uh, cracks going on and everything.
Yeah.
A rolling stone.
Babies on the knees.
A rolling, tumbling, falling, cracking, crashing.
It wasn't that bad.
We were just surprised as well.
Yeah, but you know, I think we did a pretty good job at patching her as much as patching her up.
Guide dogs should carry them as well.
Actually, I was thinking about, because I have a tiny, tiny medical kit.
I was thinking about putting that in my bag the other day and I thought... How many times?
When was the last time I even used a band-aid?
Right.
Apparently.
Yeah.
Apparently not for me.
Does she need to go to the clinic?
Oh no no, Biboo's fine.
She didn't go to the hospital.
No.
FUWAMOCO, you know.
We're just surprised.
We're not quite doctors, but we're pretty doctors.
Yeah.
You know, but she's doing much better now, so no worries.
But definitely need to keep a close eye on her.
Yeah.
No.
FUWAMOCO Why?
FUWAMOCO We're talking to Mane-chan!
FUWAMOCO And she said, FUWAMOCO Biboo!
FUWAMOCO Biboo fell off the elevator!
FUWAMOCO And Mane-chan was like, FUWAMOCO Huh?
Yeah.
You know we gotta keep an eye on her.
Otherwise next time she'll be going from the escalator to the elevator.
The elevator!
She'll be crashing right through.
Not the elevator, it was the escalator.
Okay?
Yeah.
But you know we did catch her again almost.
Almost falling, so.
I was rough.
But yeah, we got to hang out with Biboo a bit!
You know, I think recently doing a collab with Subaru-senpai, we kind of mentioned that, you know, we've been doing head spas.
Head spas recently, so you know, we thought, well, let's go together with Biboo this time!
Biboo and Toe with us!
Yeah.
But it was a lot of fun.
I know, that's all it is.
They're always super cute and kind and they whisper.
And I'm not too strong.
This time, it was pretty strong.
It's pretty strong, yeah.
I don't know how she does it.
Her strength's so long, you know?
I was like at the beginning, I'm like, oh it's kind of strong, but she'll get tired, you know?
Her grip strength, it can't last this much for that long.
Oh no.
Yeah, and you know, it's nice because they're kind and careful enough to not hurt you.
Yeah, you don't have to be bothered by that.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Hi!
It's a fuzzy Moco-chan!
Right now it's hard like a rock, but now it feels fuzzy!
Oh, I'm so fluffy!
Yeah.
But it was very, very strong.
I was impressed.
Even Biboo, Biboo was like, I was like, oh, I'm like, yeah, I was impressed.
Sometimes you have to take deep breaths.
Okay!
But it was nice that we had fun together!
Thank you Biboo for coming with us!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
She's also at Holo Explore.
But there's some more information!
Advent will be having a special pop-up store in Shibuya Tsutaya!
BAU BAU!
And even more details were just announced!
Look at all these beautiful cute illustrations here!
But you know, if you're wondering what's Shibuya Tsutaya, how do I get there?
Well, first you have to come to Japan.
That's a bit of a big trip.
But, if you go to the famous Shibuya Scramble, it's right there!
Right at the Shibuya Scramble!
And it will be starting on April 25th and will go until May 29th, so about a month long!
Ruffians!
Moco-chan!
Hi!
No, you like my outfit.
It's very pretty.
It's very nice.
Why are you laughing?
LMAO.
What does that mean?
It's very nice.
Why are you laughing?
It's the morning!
This is FUWAMOCO Morning, not FUWAMOCO Pool Time!
Clouds is part of iGrid, which is a combined figure brand together with Design Coco and IP Shoten.
And it's a part of the Vape Fruits Project.
Vape Fruits Project here in Aomori!
It'll be goods on sale as well as FUWAMOCO figure pre-orders and exhibition at the venues!
Figure pre-orders!
I wonder maybe our new business figures could be in.
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm
Off the seat.
You like Biboo's big sleeves the best.
Right!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
You can take the left side.
I'll take the right side.
Excuse me.
I'm using my jacket right now.
They are elastics but it's really cool.
It's nothing new.
Nerissa having elastics is not new.
But you know, Ruffians, I'm sure there'll be even more details coming out soon.
Maybe the next few days or so.
But it's very exciting!
Advent's pumped for the show!
Advent only!
Please look forward to it!
BAU BAU!
You can't tell but I'm very excited too.
Very excited.
I want you to be able to
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I like this now, you know?
Now we can bully Nerissa really well, right?
Right!
She looks so tidy!
We have to push her over.
Attack on Nerissa.
But you know what you could do?
You could show this!
You could show our Attack on Nerissa in LMD now!
Right!
BAU BAU!
Attack on Titan parody or something.
Right!
There's a lot of possibilities, Ruffians, so you know.
Maybe you've never touched an MMD yet.
Now is your chance!
This is the point!
I don't know, I just think it's magic.
We're looking forward to all your creative works, FUWAMOCO!
Please make lots of fun stuff.
Lots of silly stuff.
Lots of cute stuff.
All the stuff.
We're looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited!
I don't know if that's there.
BAU BAU!
I know that, you know, FUWAMOCO, we're very excited.
We like to push our excitement with you.
I'm very excited about all the other things we talked about, but there's also something that we're very excited about recently.
BAU
And, well, especially, you know, very recently, maybe... Konbini.
Konbini have been coming up more!
Especially one that makes us very happy, Family Morning!
Family Morning!
Right now, hololive English is having a collab with both Meiji and Family Morning!
You know, Meiji makes some very delicious konbini.
So, I think there's been a lot of Ruffians going, but since April 1st at 10am, there's been a special campaign going on.
At Family Mart!
If you go across all of Japan.
All Family Mart!
The convenience store.
Yeah, if you go, and you get two of the gummies and part of the campaign, you know, there's a strawberry.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
The energy drink flavor too, and I think melon soda as well.
If you get any of those following gummies to a dog, then you can get your own clear file.
And you know, these gummies, they're different than the rest of the gummies.
They are very chewy.
They're super gummies, you know.
I like them.
I don't know about you, Ruffians, but I like a gummy that you can chew on.
Yeah, you know, you get
FUWAMOCO
You can chew this one and over and over and over and over and over.
You get a clear file at random?
No, you get to chew it.
But you know you're gonna have to be like... It's a hard choice sometimes.
Sometimes you know you're just gonna have to eat a lot of gummies and you know it.
If you want all the clear files, you know what?
That's six clear files plus twelve gummy packs.
That's a lot of gummies.
But who doesn't like gummies, you know?
Right, and you can think of, you know, how can I eat this?
Eat this gummy.
You can just, you know, maybe you can put it in hidden places.
Yeah, you can take it off to the challenge, yeah!
You know, maybe you have a lot of jackets.
You can be like, I'm gonna put some gummies in this jacket pocket.
So when you forget, there's gummies.
This bag, you know, maybe you have a car, you can put it into your car.
You know, so you can be surrounded by gummies.
Whenever you know you kind of maybe need.
Whenever you forget.
So happy gummies.
Or you can give them to your friends.
Share the happiness!
If you need even more happiness, there's also acrylic standees!
And acrylic keychains!
Wow, just starting on April 8th!
At selected FUWAMIMO locations, you can also get acrylic standees!
And acrylic keychains!
Acrylic keychains are random, so good luck, Ruffians!
Good luck, whether it's acrylic standees or not.
But, well you'll have to get your paws on them soon because they're gone.
They're gone.
That's it.
And the vote, the clear file campaign still continues until April 14th.
So Ruffians, we hope that you haven't headed to FUWAMIMO yet.
Hopefully you can head over there.
Get your paws on a whole EN clear file.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Is this more waitress or maid?
Good question.
I feel like it's diner or waitress.
No percentage maid.
Huh?
Waitress, waitress, waitress both?
Ah.
Waitress
Maid Waitress Diner.
We became a diner?
I don't know!
Okay!
But it's super cute!
I love our matching outfits too!
Thank you.
And the band-aids!
Sometimes you know, we're not the best at role listening.
Band-aids are cute!
I'm a cutie.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO has 4 FUWAMOCOs!
I'm a little tired.
My jaw is tired.
There may be Ruffians who are worried about that.
Share happiness with your friends.
For example, if you have a lot of jackets, you can hide them in your pocket.
When you're feeling down, Gumi will be by your side, so you can say, yes, okay!
Oh, there's Gumi here!
Also, FUWAMOCO's recommended flavors are, of course, the Lovely flavor and Moco-chan's Cola flavor.
Also,
Ichigo.
Ichigo oishii.
Hard cola desu ne.
Cola oishii!
Soshite!
Yoka kara hajimarimashita kedo, FOMIMA no tampo de, Akustar to Akuki mo kaemasu yo!
Yoka yoka.
Hachi!
Hachi kara!
Hai!
De, eto, zenbu ne, eto, nakunacchottara owari te iu hoto nano de, hayameni te ni totte hoshii desu!
Uri kirechatta!
Eeeh!
Kote no mise ni ikanai to!
Uuun!
De, eto, homepage no hou mitetara, naka, kou iu tenpo arimasu yo, te.
Ichiran arimasu!
Uuun, naka,
There are a lot of good hints, so please take a look over there as well!
It's a really delicious gummy, and FUWAMOCO is the type to chew a lot, so if you chew a lot, you'll be able to enjoy it even more, so please try it!
BAU BAU!
It's sad that you know it's going to be ending on the 14th but we hope that you can go soon.
Hopefully you can enjoy the gummies along.
With the remains of spring.
You know, maybe you can take the acrylic stands with you, you know, on your adventures.
Maybe there's still some cherry blossoms, some sakura blossoms.
You can enjoy them together with all your sisters.
And your gummies too.
BAU BAU!
I'm just so happy, you know.
This means, you know, so many Ruffians can
I think it's time to see who's Doggie of the Day is today!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Many doggies!
See you there!
Bye-bye!
It's a full game!
And look, they're also cute!
And from the left, we have Clyde.
And then, in the middle... Ken-Ken... Ken-no-bear, Ken-no-bee.
Ken-no-bear.
And on the right, Ko-Kobe-Kobe.
So happy to spend a thousand dollars!
Which one is it?
Which one is it open?
Ken-no-bear.
Konobi.
Konobi!
Kobi?
Kobi!
But they're so cute!
But you don't!
I think... Ruffians, maybe you feel like this too, but...
Konobi
They love to run around and take naps.
I like that too!
Yeah, who doesn't love running around and taking naps?
Right?
You like that, right?
Ruffians, you know it.
No work, no school, no bills.
Sounds like a good life, right?
Run around, take naps.
Yes.
Don't be the gene, don't be the gene.
What a good life.
Right?
Yeah, you like the naps part.
Eventually though, you're like, oh, I'm not done.
Time for a run, right?
I wish you could take more naps, but I wish you could take more runs too because it's good!
It's good!
Yeah!
I feel that way too.
But look at the... I want to see what it's like all on a walk together.
I wonder if it's going to be chaotic.
Who do you think gets the ball when one ball is thrown?
Um, Koi.
BAU BAU BAU!
Clyde just looks faster.
Clyde's faster.
How does Clyde BAU BAU Moco-chan?
I think he's sort of like... BAU.
BAU.
And Kenobi!
How does Kenobi BAU BAU?
Those big ears like that!
What about Colby?
I think it will be hard to tell Kenobi and Colby apart.
No, it's very different.
The intonation is different.
I can tell them apart.
I'm sure it's always interesting with all three of them by your side.
You know who gets the right leg who gets the left side?
Maybe somebody's walking right in between your legs too, huh?
Don't trip, okay?
Yeah, and I'm sure you know probably everybody knows you at the park too.
What a cute family.
But please make sure you know that you're careful, you're equal with the distribution of treats and head parts amongst them.
It's very important.
It has to be equal.
BAU BAU!
We are FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
You know, we're talking about how good it would be to just take naps, go for runs.
Let's see where you've been going for some walks recently.
Today, I went on a walk.
We have de-den!
So blue!
A blue sky!
It's like a perfect gradient.
It's so beautiful!
I can feel the warmth too!
Yeah!
And it's so warm, it's starting to feel like summer!
I guess it is kind of mid-April now, right?
That's like summer territory, right?
Is that summer?
What do you think, Ruffians?
When is it summer to you?
When does spring stop?
When does summer start?
Not summer yet!
Summer is here!
Basically Summer at Peace.
Because Summer is May.
I do agree with Summer.
May?
May!
I kind of agree with May.
May, really?
I think so, yeah.
Oh no.
Last week of May.
Very accurate.
Last week of May, that's still a little bit right.
But you know, as for distinct smells for each season.
Yes, absolutely yes they do.
But you know FUWAMOCO, our sniffers are strong.
Yes, but I really like the smell of each and every season.
But I feel like probably it's spring and fall are the yummiest though.
I agree.
Spring is fresh and vegetables.
I feel like it's vegetables.
Maybe that's more summer.
But I feel like it's fresh like a cucumber.
You know?
You know in the morning, fall is like comfy leaves and yummy smell.
Dirt.
Barbecue.
Barbecue the leaves.
Yes, the leaves are being barbecued.
Are you going to eat that then?
I like the smell.
The dirt is going to eat the barbecue leaves.
It's good.
Yeah.
You know, you understand good.
It still feels like winter with you, hololive.
I shall get warm soon, you know.
And it'll be summer.
It'll be winter.
Summer.
Winter!
It'll be summer!
Winter.
Just like that.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad you had such a good walk.
Next!
We have our Question of the Day!
What kind of question did we get today?
De-den!
Hey FUWAMOCO!
You guys like potato chips?
If not, are there any snacks you like to have?
Beside Ponder Wings.
Ponder Wings aren't just snacks.
Ponder Wings are life.
BAU BAU!
MAMA!
Ruffians!
What do you think, huh?
Take a chip and eat it.
Good question.
I feel like you don't like chips.
You like fries.
I'm glad you like fries.
I have some fries and chips for you and me.
I don't really like super oily foods that much, you know.
But if we do eat chips, what's your favorite, Moco-chan?
My favorite!
It's all done, baby!
You know, really, really vinegary and salty.
I really like sour stuff, right?
So I feel like that's what it falls in now.
Ruffians, you're like so vinegar too!
I thought you'd be like... It's so crazy I like it!
Vinegar really really strong!
You don't like so so much that your mouth feels like a little funny afterwards.
You know like every time you take a bite and you have a chip, it's like you can feel like a minus two HP?
That kind?
Yeah.
Yeah, they're too sour for you.
It's okay, we'll eat them then.
Yeah.
Maybe sometime.
It does kind of hurt though, and then afterwards you're kind of like... Maybe I shouldn't have had that.
Yeah, but it's good fun.
But I think all in all though, we don't really eat snacks that much.
Does Kamekama bar count?
Yeah.
You know, the imitation crab bar.
Yeah, Kamekama bar!
I don't know if that counts as a snack though.
It counts.
Ruffians say yes.
If we have a snack, then we have that as a snack.
But we don't really have snacks.
BAU BAU!
Pongering is not a snack, Ruffians!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
And thank you for your submissions, too, you know.
Remember, you know, if you have a dog the other day, like, oh, that was a cute dog.
Maybe you saw a bunch of dogs.
Or you happen to see a very nasty Pero.
Or you have a question.
Please!
Use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
And let us know what you did.
What's up!
Same!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians.
Our next stream!
We have another stream coming up.
It's pretty amazing.
Are you ready?
Tonight we have some important homework that we need to get done.
But!
I'm ready for this.
Get ready for this.
We'll be... De-den!
On Saturday at 6pm, we'll be doing a membership together with the Doggy Pack!
I'm using thumbnail, alright?
I wanna play Fall Guys, FUWAMOCO fans!
I wanna play Fall Guys!
Moco-chan's like... I wanna play Fall Guys!
Can we play Fall Guys?
I don't know...
Yeah!
If that's what you think yo!
Four guys!
You know?
I wanna play four guys.
You kinda wanna chat?
That's what we were thinking!
We were thinking, you know, we could play four guys and then we could kinda chat!
You better play as Ruffians!
It seems like Ruffians kinda... If that's what Ruffians are thinking of then... That's what I'm kinda thinking of.
If that's what you wanna do, let's go on it, okay?
I'm looking forward to it, Ruffians!
Thank you!
I will also be showing up somewhere else too, so... You have to catch us once you can find out about it.
Okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I'm looking forward to that!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU BANDAI!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Crystallize!
BAU BAU!
Woohoo!
Steve!
BAU BAU!
I got a banana!
Dude!
BAU BAU!
Wax!
Mini bunny!
BAU BAU!
Two fingers!
Abahuchi!
BAU BAU!
Ramon!
DEFCON!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!